will you have playoff games where you
determine seating based on win
percentage all of those things shireen
will be handled by the commissioner with
the advice of that
advisory committee that outside
committee champ bailly
isaac bruce charlie castle tom coughlin
marvin lewis troy palamalo bill polian
and rick smith
and uh you know the reaction i saw last
night on social media not that we ever
should pay attention to any reaction on
social media at any time
but i'm going to go ahead and pay
attention to this one people are saying
well where are the doctors where are the
epidemiologists they're missing the
point here
this isn't advice for how to deal with
the pandemic this is advice for how to
deal with the competitive issues
relating to football that the pandemic
may cause
not from the standpoint of controlling
the virus or limiting the spread
but from the standpoint of this team has
x number of players who aren't available
this week
should we expect them to go forward is
there another way to handle this
up to and including how do we handle
playoff seating if some teams don't play
all 16
games that's what they're there for so
this isn't a medical group this is a
football group
that is there to deal with football
issues because there's an
acknowledgement the competition
committee has
obvious conflicts of interest because
these decisions
are going to affect their teams directly
or indirectly once we get into the
season when we're talking about
who has to play who doesn't have to play
who gets to the playoffs who doesn't get
to the playoffs
every member of the competition
committee is going to have an obvious
bias
when it comes to that so they've created
this separate committee and
i i don't have a problem with it
conceptually shireen
i just i i wish there was a rule book
that would apply that's what that's what
i want because i don't know how this is
going to play out in practice and i
don't think anybody does
yeah i don't think they know how it's
going to play out in practice you know i
do think they're following baseball and
what's going on there with some gains
postponed and
i do think they are planning for the
plan b
if that happens in football what if a
team
can't play that week or for two weeks or
for however long it is
i do think they have a plan in place
there is a playbook there will they
follow it
this committee's good i do wonder
how many people he asks roger goodell
asked but that said no that wouldn't do
it i mean i i would think that you would
want a peyton manning and a tony dungy
on that committee did he ask them to be
on the committee we don't know we don't
know how many people were asked and how
many turned it down and maybe
didn't want to do it but this is a good
thing i think for the nfl for that we
don't have the conflict of interest it's
almost like a competition committee
of outsiders that are going to decide
things for the nfl and minus all the
uh competitive things that would go on
within the competition committee this
this is going to be good i think for
for roger goodale to consult with these
guys who have been in the game and know
the game very well and look as
as chris and i argued yesterday there
still is an extent
of potential conflict of interest
because these individuals
at some level or another have
friendships from when they were in the
league have
enemies from when they were in the
league they have people they like people
they don't like
and and you never know who's thinking
about maybe a path back so you want
someone who can set
all of that aside it's the jury pull
that's what they
ultimately need people who have no bias
no interest
and and it's impossible to get to that
point because if you find eight people
like that
they don't know anything about football
they're not connected to the sport at
all they're just random people you find
on the street and that's not going to do
the commissioner any good when it's time
to make these tough decisions and
ultimately the commissioner is going to
be making the decisions
i like the fact that it's a blend of
players coaches and general managers
and you mentioned peyton manning you
mentioned tony dungey
i think peyton manning would have been a
perfect uh person to add here
i just wonder because there's that sense
he's definitely going to get in
at some point and the universe of teams
that maybe he would end up with
i think people on the inside know the
candidates for where he potentially
could go i wonder if that
you know in a roundabout way made it
awkward because even though he's not
currently with a team
there may be teams that he would be
subconsciously not deliberately
favoring or disfavoring i i just i you
can't completely wipe that away that's
one of my concerns and just hopefully
everyone acknowledges that
and the commissioner acknowledges that
when it's time to make these decisions
because that is the one thing that just
still
that combined with the lack of clear
standards still kind of gnaws at me
well ultimately roger goodell is going
to be blamed for whatever happens
or accredited frankly for that matter
too although he's not credited for much
but he is blamed for a lot but
whatever happens it is his decision he's
just leaning on these people to
to see what they think and uh he may go
against the committee who knows when it
comes down to it but
there are going to be some hard
decisions to make here there are going
to be teams that test positive
for kova that have a number of players
test positive for covid
there are going to be quarterbacks who
test positive for covet we know that is
likely to happen
and they're going to be hard decisions
to make he has this committee to consult
ultimately it is his decision to make uh
and and
and they'll be tough decisions and the
the game
probably will go on maybe with or
without a game that week but
but i think you know the goal obviously
is to get through a complete and full
season and we'll see if they're able to
do that baseball was not able to do that
has not been able to do that and i think
baseball
they've had a pretty good couple weeks
here but i i think they're only a you
know a
handful of games more from from shutting
this thing down if it continues
to have games canceled and postponed
sharing i'm curious for your thoughts on
this because sims and i have been
talking about it discussing it and i've
come around to chris's way of thinking
you know football in my mind is the
ultimate next man up sport
we've never talked about possibly
postponing a game based upon the fact
that a team has too many
injuries you get somebody elevated from
the practice squad you sign someone off
the street you make
your plans you set up your roster
accordingly especially this year there's
going to be a premium
on players who can do multiple things
you can play offensive line you can play
defensive line if need be i mean it's
bill belichick's dream
i got a receiver who can play corner i
got a safety who can play running back i
got all these guys who can
just be football players i think that
the the attitude should be
it's on you to keep your guys healthy
it's on you to have 46 guys in uniform
ready to go
you've got 69 guys between the active
roster and the practice squad
so you can withstand an outbreak and
it's on you to ensure that you're ready
so look i understand that they don't
want to just have forfeits
and have to rebate money to the networks
because there's no game to televise on a
sunday night or a monday night or a
thursday night or a sunday at 4 25
p.m eastern for what is one of the
bigger games of the week
but i i think there's something very
simple
and very powerful in taking the position
that for all 32 teams
you're expected to have 46 guys healthy
every week and it's on you to make sure
it happens
i think there's two things that i agree
with you it is the next man up sport we
hear that
that cliche all the time but i think
there's two things that that would
lead to postponed games one is the
quarterback position
if you have your room full of
quarterbacks and you do not have a
legitimate quarterback to start a game
i think you seriously have to consider
that a team
would postpone that game if it's say
three queues
i assume every team is going to carry at
least three quarterbacks
this year i think you have to you know
we see a lot of teams normally go to
that two quarterbacks we're going to
save the roster position
this year i'm pretty sure every team is
going to have three quarterbacks maybe
they quarantine that third guy
if you have that third quarterback maybe
they this committee and roger goodell
say okay go ahead you're gonna have to
play with your third quarterback good
luck to you
but if you get your quarterbacks all
hurt and you're having to bring or
injured and covet or whatever the case
may be and you have to bring in a fourth
quarterback from outside i think that's
when you have to think about it
and the other thing is if you have a
string a cluster of cases
within the offensive line because then i
think you start worrying about injuries
injuries to the quarterback injuries to
the running backs uh big big
type injuries that that we could see in
the game if you can't have a decent
offensive line out there now
they're gonna have probably 10 offensive
linemen so they should be able to put an
offensive line out there but say you get
six cases seven cases within your
offensive line
in that offensive line room then i think
you have to start thinking about
postponing
the game but to me those are the only
two things that i would think about
postponing a game four
not a legitimate quarterback starting
you're bringing somebody in from outside
or the offensive line really has a
cluster of cases in a week
yeah god forbid somebody'd have to sign
colin kaepernick this year that would be
a shame
if it came down to that but but you know
i shireen to get back to the point we
were making earlier about how
linear coaches are in there here's where
i am here's where i need to be what do i
need to do to get there
you tell them going in hey you got to
have 46 people ready
it's up to them to say well i better
make sure i keep my quarterbacks apart i
better make sure that the offensive line
is
i mean i just i think it's just easier
and it's cleaner to just put it on the
teams
but apparently that's not gonna be the
case there's gonna be that that out that
escape hatch if need be
but we don't know what the standards
will be we don't know what the rules
will be
and we won't know anything about how
that actually operates
until it does hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports